[Music]
Nick Cannon is a dad once again it's
outstanding man I mean honestly it's one
of those things where even an unexpected
situation you still embrace the beauty
of bringing a life into this world
because that's what life is all about
the TV personality shared the exciting
news on Instagram posting his new son's
first picture his name golden Segen
Canon this is Nick's first child with
ex-girlfriend Brittany Bell he has two
children with ex-wife Mariah Carey twins
rock and roll how will you bring
everybody of the whole family together
big fam come on Nick AB you black you
know how to do if you don't it's trust
me I know you know it but that's that's
such-and-such daddy that's also your
auntie your brother you know you got a
brother across the street we guys is all
we all come together but it's all out of
unconditional love man and everybody's
in great spirits so it's I'm not one of
those people that I like to separate and
create animosity and stuff like I try to
make every environment every situation
I'm in a peaceful environment nothing
everybody else follows to us all up
you